civil rights attorney Ben Crump was here
earlier he's back he's been called the
african-american family emergency plan
he gained national recognition back in
2012 during the Trayvon Martin case
since then he's been by the side of many
people seeking justice including the
families of Tamir rice Michael Brown and
most recently both them John
his new book is called open season
legalized genocide of color people Crump
examines how racist practices within the
criminal justice system impact America
from police brutality to voter
suppression Ben Crump thank you very
much for joining us once again at the
table thank you you said that in the
book you write living in constant fear
is paralyzing demoralizing you can kill
your ambition and your outlook racism is
a tool in genocide genocide is such a
strong word it is but it is appropriate
to draw attention to what's happening
most people are thinking that we see
another hashtag so often that it gets
attention for one day yeah yeah think
about all the hashtags we've seen in
just this year and the crux of the
problem that you see is what exactly it
is certainly implicit bias and where I
really try to focus on in this book is
holding a mirror to America's face to
say America we can do better this book
endeavors to make all races confront our
biases because we need to admit that
there's a problem you know one in five
black men and Tennessee and Florida and
many of the other states have similar
statistics or convicted felons if it
continues they believe in the next 25
years one in three black men would be
convicted felons and so when I think
about the inspiration of the book I'd go
back to send the young people protesting
in Ferguson right in the aftermath of
Michael Brown Gale and there was this
one young man I remember specifically
who confronted the National go head
that's not rightful pointed at him and
he said go ahead and kill me now with
all the cameras here you
Kilis anyway when they're gone and he
said it's important that the wall sees
how you all are killing us in that state
of my mind it's important then a lot of
people are uncomfortable having this
conversation yeah how do we have it well
it's a necessary conversation we have it
because we want to do better as a
society but how do we really start it
you started by being honest you look at
the empirical data we have empirical
evidence here that we talk about those
things that even though black men make
up only 7% of the population in America
we make up almost 50% of the population
on death row so you have to admit that
one or two things either black men or
some terrible evil criminal minded
people or our criminal justice system is
racist and discriminatory and I've
choose to believe that black men are no
worse than any other man in America
here's here's the very hard part which
is implicit bias is a real thing I don't
think anyone argue against it it takes a
lifetime though embedded in our society
to become bias in that way so how do you
train that out of somebody in like a 15
hour session or a weekend or something
like that it's never gonna happen in the
15 hours says we can retreat what
happens training it's like a one day
training of everyone at corporations do
this but we're the solution each and
every one of the solution we know it's
not going to happen in eight hours 750
on said every day we have to try to
better ourselves we have to look at
situations whether in the courtroom
where black and brown people or sinners
of twice as much as white people and say
there's something wrong with that we
can't as dr. King says see injustice and
see evil and look the other way
you know bystander yeah you have a
chapter called white men are not shot in
the back and you give several examples
of unarmed black men who are killed and
yet there are white suspects who have
done mass shootings that are still alive
can you talk about that absolutely you
know two things Gail even with it
is hands up don't shoot black people
brown people are killed in some of the
most unbelievable ways when they have
encounters with police officers Michael
Brown was walking and hands up no
shooting Ferguson then you have Ernest
Hoskins so we talk about a young man who
was having a debate with his boss in
front of his three employees and his
boss blew his head off and claims stand
your ground and then you see Pamela
Turner who's having a mental illness
crisis and the police officer shoots her
five times while she's on the ground and
he's on his feet and so you said on the
other side you have Dylan roof shooting
their parkland Florida and white men who
are confirmed mass murderers are
arrested and protected case they take
him to Burger King after they know he's
killed nine of the most innocent people
you could ever find but Stefan Clark
Fernando could steal all these black men
if they move a certain way they are shot
and killed and so it's the implicit bias
that we have to not fear one another we
have to reach out to one another well
you have solutions you say change the
focus of criminal justice reform to
transformation rethink incarceration
think successful rehabilitation
absolutely there's a better way that we
can make this world better for all our
children and let them know that all our
lives matter
I honestly think Carroll all our lives
matter and although
there's no such thing really I sitting
on the sidelines on this one you that
isn't itself is taking a position mr.
Crump we appreciate you being here the
book open season is on sale right now